- You've had another baby this year.
You were just talking about it.
So that's, I am a mom as
well and work as well.
And that's a hard thing to balance.
Are you finding that hard?
- I mean, last night I
was up a good four times
in the night, you know, like, waiting,
"Do I put the paci in, do I not?"
- Did you sleep train?
Are you doing sleep training?
- [Kirsten] We're in
the midst of it, yeah.
- Oh, you're in hell.
- Yeah, I am.
But my friend taught me a trick
to just put like 20 pacis around them.
So they just go like this
and there, they find one.
- 100 percent.
- You know, just like as
many as can go in that crib.
- Yeah, throw them all in.
- Yeah, all of them.
- And especially the ones
with the little like penguins attached
and all the little things.
- Oh, I don't do those for some reason.
- Oh, they, yeah, they gave them to me
and I just put anything in
there to get them to stop, yeah.
- It's like, how do you wash them though?
Wash the?
- [Kelly] The washing machine.
You can put that part, yeah.
- You just throw the whole thing in?
- Yeah, I think we did.
- With the paci attached.
- I don't know if we were supposed to,
I'm pretty sure we did.
- I don't know, I'm always
like, how do you wash it?
It seems gross.
Like it keeps dropping on the floor,
it has a stuffed animal that's
just like sweeping the floor.
- I know, I wasn't a
good like first-time mom.
I was like, "That's free probiotics."
I'm like, if it was on the
floor, I'm like, "You're fine."
So is it true though
that your three-year-old
calls you treat mom?
- Treat mom, yes,
because I guess I give
him a lot of treats.
And he also calls me trash mom too,
because I take all his trash.
- That's different sounding.
- I know.
I'm treat mom and trash mom.
- [Kelly] Trash mom is
a whole different story.
- I know, It's literally
like, "Here, I'm done."
That's why he calls me trash mom.
- I love it, oh, I love it.
- Because when he's done, yeah.
- Oh, yeah, I've started
implementing, my kids,
I'm like, "Oh, look at
those legs you have.
"You can walk it on over yourself."
Yeah, they're five and seven.
Mine are a little older, but yeah.
But have you had any chance to
like take time for yourself?
I know it's hard, like
as moms, we always feel,
I feel like all my
girlfriends that are moms,
you get that guilt of like
having time for yourself,
but it's like so important.
Do you do that?
- I also have the guilt of like,
I can't sit and watch a television show.
Like if they're in the other room,
you know, I just feel
like I don't have, yeah,
I haven't done really much
for myself, it's true.
- Yeah, oh, do it.
- Yeah, like once in a while
I'll go do something for my mental health
like go do a Pilates class,
even just to get my strength back
because I just felt like I
was hunched over in a chair
for three months, you know what I mean?
It was like-
- 100 percent.
- [Kirsten] Yeah.
- Girl, I think that's
all I do in all my jobs.
I sit in a chair.
- I know, getting hair and makeup done.
- [Kelly] That's all I do.
- Yeah, me too, just
sitting in different chairs.
- My hips are almost 40.